يبدو ان افغانستان التي تتهم فيها طالبان
بالسعي لتمص حقوق الانسان كافه وبخاصه
حقوق المراه على موعد مع تغيير سياسي من
احد العالمين ببواطن الامور رحمه الله
نبيل الذي كان يشغل سابقا منصب رئيس
الاستخبارات الافغانيه قرر ان يعود الى
الساحه لكن ليس من باب الامن هذه المره
وانما من باب السياسه العوده لن تكون على
الارض بالتاكيد وانما من خارج الحدود لان
الوضع الحليب حرج ومعقد لكن رغم ذلك لابد
من محاوله لتشكيل حزب يشارك في الحياه
السياسيه نبيل اعلن عن تشكيل الحزب تحت
اسم حزب الحريه الوطنيه الافغاني مؤكدا
انه يريد حكومه لا مركزيه اضاف ان مجلس
القياده فيه مؤقت حتى التشاور مع بقيه
الاطراف الراغبه بالانضمام الى الحزب
الجديد
ثم الاعلان عن مجلس القياده واعضاء الحزبه
الخطوط العريضه لاجنده الحزب عكسها اعلان
التاسيس من نبيل حيث اتهم طالبان
بالاستلاء على السلطه في عام 2021 لكن هو
ارجع الامر لصفقه خارجيه وسوء اداره
داخليه حولت جميعها افغانستان في النهايه
الى بؤره للارهاب الدوليه
[موسيقى]
م بلادنا الى طالباننا نتيجه صفقه
الخارجيه في الخامس عشر من اغسطس 2020
ونتيجه لسوء اداره قاده الحكومات السابقه
وخاصه اشرف غني الذي فر من البلاد بعد ان
اصبحت افغانستان بؤره للارهاب الدولي وشعب
افغانستان يعاني من انتهاكا لحقوق الانسان
وحقوق المراه والاباده الجماعيه الى جانب
انتهاكات الكرامه الانسانيه والفصل
العنصريه بين الجنسين وضد الاقليات
وذكر نبيل بان اطلاق الحزب ياتي من اجل
الوصول الى فتره انتقاليه لحكومه جديده
بهدف اقامه نظام سياسي شرعي وتحكيم
القانون على اساس القيم العالميه
للديمقراطيه والاراده الحره للشعب
الافغاني واشار الى ان الحزب يمكنه النضال
مع باقي الافغان بشكل مشترك لانقاذ البلاد
من خلال تشكيل الجبهه الوطنيه المتحده
التي تضم احزان سياسيه ومؤسسات المجتمع
المدني والشخصيات المستقله في البلاد نبيل
حذر من ان افغانستان على وشك السقوط في
مستنقع الحروب الداخليه الداميه وحدوث
كارثه انسانيه لا يمكن اصلاحها ووجهها
كلامه لطالبان لم يفوت الاوان بعد التوقف
عن فرد المزيد من العنف والاكراه واحتكار
السلطه وقام يا حرياتي لم يفوت الاوان
للقبول باراده الشعب الافغانيه